[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes I'm James Hill The Spectators
political correspondent and your host
for this week's episode
coming up on the show Robert Hartman
writes about the coronation he'll be
joining me to discuss with the historian
Jeremy black we already know there's
going to be protests and that's why
we've got the chief executive Republic
the staunch anti-monthist group on to
discuss with graham Smith
in Westminster trouble is brewing over
kierstama's attempted appointment of Sue
gray as his chief of staff what does all
this mean for the government civil
service and cabinet secretary Simon case
Katie balls will be joining me to
discuss later today
up in Scotland the SMB this week
celebrated their 16th anniversary in
power join me to discuss all this and
how it's gone in recent days is Alex
salmon the former first minister of
Scotland Ben Lazarus interviews The
Godfather of AI Jeffrey Hinton in this
week's magazine I'll be joined by Toby
ORD Oxford academic to discuss this and
the wide debate on artificial
intelligence and finally Lionel Shriver
writes in this week's magazine about
Tucker Carlson I want Nathan so
appealing she'll be joining me later to
discuss her TV watching habits before we
get going thanks to our bullet sponsors
can I call genuity Wealth Management for
sporting the show can a quarter
experience wealth planners and
investment managers who offer unwavering
support in challenging times visit
candywealth.com for more information and
to celebrate the coronation of King
Charles III you can subscribe to The
Spectator and get the next 10 weeks for
the price of one not only that but
they'll send you a commemorative
spectator Mark absolutely free
coronation of King Charles in just a few
days are here happening in Westminster a
few hundred meters away from our office
on 22 Old Queen Street and that's why
we've temporarily moved Studio but we'll
hope to be back there next week join me
to discuss the coronation is the
historian and journalist and writer
Robert Hartman as well as the academic
Jeremy black to discuss how coronations
have traditionally taken place in
Britain over the centuries Robert you're
right in this week's magazine about the
coronation and what king Charles's Reign
is likely to look like you say there's
been a bit of grumbling about how last
minute it's all been tell us about that
uh well it's it's has been pretty last
minute I mean there are still elements
of it that we aren't sure about uh if
you look back to 53
um you had over a year and a half of
planning and really by the
um six months out I think most of the
people involved knew what they were
going to be doing whereas with this
coronation partly because they've had
less time to plan it you've got people
who've only in the last few days have
found out you know their particular
roles and also people who found out that
they don't have no role at all people
who found out that who probably thought
they would maybe get an invitation and
discover they're not
um and that's partly a byproduct of the
fact that um The Abbey is not going to
be filled with grandstands this time I
mean in 1953 they shut down the Abbey in
January and installed a railway to be
able to build these extraordinary
gantries and tear upon tear of seating
right up literally up to the rafters and
that enabled eight and a half thousand
people to squeeze in this time it's just
over two thousand so inevitably a lot of
people are disappointed I've heard quite
a lot of people in this morning because
there are a lot of categories are not
plus one uh in 1953 if you have
limitation you could bring your spouse
that's not happening this time I think a
lot a lot number of people who are
invited are quite upset and then you've
got a number of people and I'd say in
the piece uh particularly
members of the uh hereditary peerage I'm
quite upset that they're not us because
their families have been part of this
extraordinary event for centuries and
and this time they're not there at all
Jeremy what do you make of the
coronation preparations and the news
last week that people are being
encouraged to say oath to allegiance to
Charles III
well I think coronation proceedings have
always varied and I mean I agree I
thought Robert's piece was excellent and
his life of the queen was really the
best available as well but it's worth
bearing in mind if you look back at
coronations you look at the coronation
of George II for example in
um 1727. these are often chaotic
occasions uh the coronation of George IV
was a chaotic occasion so I think one
has to bear in mind that
um if you slow down history and look at
it in detail you often find confusion
chaos people having around people having
a tease
um the key thing is how it will look in
hindsight and there's no reason to
believe that this will not look anything
other than an impressive coronation and
part of an impressive Reign I mean I
agree with Robert's piece the king does
seem to be enjoying himself I agree with
him he's uh the king is an amazing
example of soft power and an enabler and
as Robert says immobilizer and I think
you know there is no reason to believe
that the coronation will not be seen as
anything other than excellent start to
the next stage of the rain and obviously
we're hoping it won't be as chaotic some
of those past ones Robert but what are
the other differences other than
obviously you mention the huge reduction
in a number of people going that unlike
1953 what are the other kind of key
differences from the last time we did
this 70 years ago well Jeremy here on a
very important point there and thank you
for your kind remarks but um yeah you're
absolutely right I mean they were uh
often disastrous but it didn't really
matter that much because the only people
who could see what went on were the
people who were really close to the the
action you know even those in the Nave
had no idea what was going on up in the
in the theater the you know in between
the two transepts
um this is the first if you like made
for TV coronation the last one was not
the last one there was a big debate uh
well-known debate
um for the first few months about
whether it should be televised at all
and the view of the Queen and Churchill
and others and particularly the
Archbishop of Canterbury was that it
should not be televised because the
Archbishop did not want any mistakes and
there was a long history of archbishops
making pretty disastrous mistakes so it
was really any relatively late in the
day Churchill mother Queen and Churchill
acquiesce said right you can televise uh
most of it but you can't obviously
televise the anointing and you can't
televise uh the Holy Communion so it was
sort of partially televised this time
and also if you look at the cameras
there was a deal done it's it's it's
it's sort of in all the documents it
says and no close-ups in capital letters
as part of the deal with the BBC this
time everything is going to be
beautifully shot by the BBC and watched
by billions around the world in a way
that the last one simply wasn't and I do
think that that's that's sort of an
absolute Game Changer if you like in in
terms of
um how how it will look and and Jeremy's
absolutely right I mean I I've always
found the Royal events you have these
School and arguments and the run-up
every single one I mean with the wedding
of Harry and Megan it was Megan's dad
with the wedding of William and Kate it
was the issue of uh Blair and brown not
being invited why is the Syrian
Ambassador on the list with the wedding
of Charles and Camilla in 2005. there
was a whole problem to do with the
licensing Arrangements it had to move to
the Town Hall in Windsor and then the
pope died which forced the whole thing
back by a day and time after time the
golden jubilee I mean you know the poor
Queen she lost her mother and her sister
just weeks before it started so you you
have this history of these big Royal
events which seem to be beset by one
problem after another in the run-up and
then they come along and they're
brilliant and everyone goes wow wasn't
that amazing and I'm pretty sure that at
probably about 6 p.m on a Saturday
afternoon everybody will be sort of
sitting around going well that really
was something wasn't it and if it wasn't
then well this will be on the internet
you come back and laugh for me next week
I you write your piece Robert that
Charles is a great traditionist I mean
looking ahead to the months after
um you know and it started with rain
this is going to be sort of informing
how he conducts the monarchy going
forward because there's been some debate
around him being a modernizer as well
yeah I'm sure that you know there are
going to be a constant
um run of sort of modernizing touches
there's a lot of stuff that goes with
Obsession to the throne that simply
hasn't been touched on yet I mean uh for
example I just pluck one out of thin air
but I mean you've got all the Royal
warrant holders they're all waiting to
see what happens because those run out
fairly shortly
everything to do with what sort of you
know Royal transport how are they going
to reconfigure Buckingham Palace who's
going to be doing what in the royal
family I mean all these are decisions
yet to come I mean at the moment the
focus is is very squarely on on let's go
through the coronation Jeremy in terms
of um what sort of changed this time and
what hasn't has been kept what kind of
traditions have been kept for this
coronation and uh you know how does this
much marker break with the past and a
continuation what's come before it
I think a lot of it is um continuation
but I I I'd like to take up that last
point about modernization the last great
modernizer was Albert you know as it
were Queen Victoria's Albert and he had
a vision for what the monarchy could
mean and should mean in a modernizing
Britain and I think that in his own way
uh the new king will be a kind of more
subtle because uh Prince Albert was not
particularly subtle a more subtle
example of the same and Albert was very
important in moving the monarchy forward
from the rather tired shape it had been
under with George IV and William IV and
giving it an enormous you know boost of
Life helping to make it a really active
part of the British constitution and I
think that for the king the new king the
problem is the British constitution and
the nature of divided politics it's not
him I mean it's how he interacts with
actually a public which is not terribly
at these always with itself and with the
politics that's quite divided and that
against the context also of separatist
political movements the possible future
of Northern Ireland within maybe a
different constitutional political
context all of these are challenges for
him and I think we're Jolly lucky we've
got an intelligent active and thoughtful
Monarch on the stage at the present
moment yeah I'm just to round us up
Robert I mean this is obviously we're
talking about the coronation it's going
to be very happy instead of every day
and all likelihood but we've seen you
know the rise of not my king movements
as well lots of protests across the
country where he's been going as well
and as Jeremy says it's quite a
challenging time for the monarchy and
the country as well
he wasn't always perhaps the most
politically Adept at some of these
things do you think there's a he needs a
chance to step up will it be quite a
challenge for him which he says King uh
I I think he's given a lot of thought I
think there is this uh idea that you
know he he's going to have to learn to
button his lip as I say in the piece and
actually I mean you know this is a guy
who's been doing uh uh public duties
um for longer than most people in this
country being alive I mean he was
starting uh Royal duties back in the 60s
um you know he's been heir to the throne
for longer than anybody else has ever
been so he's had a pretty uh good time
to dwell on it and think about it
um I I Jeremy made some very good very
interesting point Sarah and I think he
he does face uh a pretty you might say
Bleak
um Horizon with with you know issues to
do with the Union uh I mean that's got
to be number one I mean you know he's
he's King of the UK I mean how much of
that remains okay and how you does it
remain United I mean those are those are
serious issues so you've got the whole
issue of the the other Realms which she
becomes king of or is now king of 14
Realms and those you know some of those
are are very now vociferously Republican
and so uh I think it's safe to say some
of them will go Republican how do you um
sort of separate how do you how do you
de-personalize that so that it doesn't
become
um a a sort of almost a vote of no
confidence in Charles III I mean on that
point I think he I think he is very good
I I think he's he's um very sympathetic
he's he's a clever man uh he's very
cultured
um I I'm trying to think of a of a
monarch who has had quite such as a love
of the Arts I think you probably have to
go back to someone like George III maybe
you know 12 New pieces uh commissioned
just for this coronation so you know
he's he's a deep thinker
um now is is that an asset maybe it is
maybe it isn't we'll we'll have to see
but I mean he he does have uh all sorts
of problems ahead but I think the key
thing we always have to remember is
everybody particularly the the you
mentioned the protesters there they're
not my king law they're a tiny minority
I mean I've seen them in action you know
but they're vocal but they're tiny
minority
um but but you know what what we have to
remember is he can't do everything uh
people say well why hasn't he done this
why hasn't he apologized for that why
isn't he I mean so much of what uh gets
thrown at the monarchy it's not really
up to them it it you know they're a
constitutional monarchy
um and as I say my piece you know people
said why didn't you go to cop27 you know
why doesn't he do this he he does have
to do what his government and his
ministers um tell him and I think
actually
a reminder of that comes right at the
start of this coronation service for the
first time you'll have this this is this
sort of moment where a chorister comes
up and effectively says to him what are
you doing here and he says I'm here as a
servant and I think it's a reminder to
all of us yeah fundamentally he he does
actually do what we tell him to do we
don't do what he tells us to do just
remember that
thank you Robert and thank you Jeremy
of course not everyone is happy about
the coronation joining me now is Graeme
Smith the chief executive of Republic
the storage anti monarchist group who
think that's a little bit of a sham
uh Graham thank you for joining us today
uh just first of all how will you be
marking the coronation on Saturday
uh well we're going to be protesting uh
on Trafalgar Square at the edge of the
coronation so uh we will be very visible
and very loud so um making our Mark and
making sure that we uh cannot be ignored
um just to really drive home the point
that we're no longer a nation of
royalists really and there needs to be a
serious debate about the future of the
molecule and do you feel that that
hasn't really taken place yet um Talk us
through the kind of last six seven
months or so since your session of King
Charles because it was often said that
you know Elizabeth II was the monarchy's
best asset in the UK in terms of being
seen as quite a successful Monarch I
think by everyone regardless of
political persuasion what has Charles
meant for Republic and the Republican
movement
yeah I mean we've had a massive boost in
support and we're seeing the uh quite a
significant shift in the polling
certainly from
um people saying they support the
monarchy to sort of being unsure so they
don't knows have gone up as well but
some polling uh puts us up uh by 10
points uh the monarchy down by about 20
points so um whereas typically around 75
is now consistently under 16.
um
and uh yeah I mean we've had a massive
influx of supporters and uh money
um so we're now able to do a much bigger
protest than we might have done uh
previously the the big difference is
that the monarchy was the queen I mean I
think it's more than she was their asset
she was the monarchy for most people and
Charles isn't the queen and that's
that's his biggest problem uh and um and
I think the the mood uh the sort of the
background music has changed as well and
um I think the spell has been broken
people don't really think of them as
being exceptional or Beyond criticism
anymore
suppose really I mean we've been here in
some ways a bit before in the 1990s the
monarchy had a different support and
then of course they recovered and I
think people perhaps took a second look
and see the queen did many years of
service Etc why is it different this
time why what's not to say King Charles
might be seen as a very successful
Monarch and previous monarchs have done
adapt to The Changing Times maybe reform
the institution perhaps and you know we
might see the polls actually changing
the probably become more monarchist in
their support
well I think that I think it's highly
unlikely that the the things will turn
around I mean they're long-term
projections
um done by uh sort of these um social
attitude surveys suggested there's been
a general decline over the last 30 years
even though it has sort of gone bumped
up and down but I don't think it went
down quite as much in the 1990s but the
queen was still there and we still had
another 20 odd 30 years of the queen in
order to sort of turn that around so
they carefully managed what was going on
a lot of it also was uh more um around
sort of weddings uh oh sorry marriages
failing and that sort of thing very
personal stuff and they kind of pushed
people like Edward and uh Andrew to the
sidelines to some extent and then of
course they had William and Harry who
certainly in the first 10 years of this
uh Century um were probably seen as uh a
big help to the image but all that's
gone now so we now have had the Andrew
Scandal dragging on for 11 12 years
we've had the massive Route Around Harry
and Megan which has divided royalists as
well as other opinion
um and of course the queen is no longer
there to to turn it around she was kind
of there he actually deflected an awful
lot of criticism and
um and concerns
um in a way that Charles just doesn't
and I think that is a concern uh for
them because I don't think they're going
to be able to turn that around I think
this is a downward trajectory and at
some point in the next decade or so uh
we will see fewer than a 50 percent uh
supporting the monarchy and then they're
in quite a lot of trouble
and that's really interesting you talk
about individuals there when you see
people joining up Republic talking to
people who sort of as you say seeing
this surge in the polls I mean what is
it so much is it to do with the
individuals of the royal family uh or is
it perhaps a sense of maybe the
institution isn't as responsive or
popular as it once was
I think there's an instinctive sort of
understanding that it's not Democratic
and we probably shouldn't have it and
people sort of tolerate it because they
think it's good for the economy and
other people like it and so on
um but I think an awful lot of that was
also wrapped up in the queen people were
happy to sort of make an allowance for
the queen to continue being the queen
which they're not uh that sort of
generosity doesn't extended to Charles
so they're they're sort of
core instincts as Democrats are kicking
in more more fiercely and I think that
most people have grown up where with the
queen already on the throne so it's kind
of you know a fixture of British life
whereas now we've actually witnessed a
succession we now have seen this man
who's been printed towns all our lives
suddenly become King Charles with
headlines around you know lack of
payment of inheritance tax and headlines
around um
the how wealthy is and uh and all this
kind of thing and then huge questions
over why we have a coronation which is
not required there's no legal or
constitutional requirement for it um but
a coronation is going to cost by some
estimates a quarter of a billion pounds
during the cost of living crisis so I
think it it you know they've lost their
um their star player and it's they've
also lost their star player at a pretty
difficult time for the country and I
think that also plays into
and finally Graham I just want to ask I
mean do you think there's a danger
perhaps with the protests of the
coronation Etc that you know Republic
might have a very worthy argument Etc
but is there not a danger that you're
playing into perhaps opponent
stereotypes of being quite Earnest
puritanical uh killjoys as they say what
would you say to that and is there a
danger perhaps of Republic's uh image
maybe clouding some of its goals and
achievements so I mean let's remember
that most people are not interested in
the uh Jubilee there's nine percent
enthusiasm people will watch on TV but I
think that
um you know I think most people will
understand that there is a need to
protest these sorts of things but also
we will not be uh you know we're being
quite deliberate in trying to keep the
mood light and you know there's going to
be speeches there'll also be music and
they'll just be
um engagement with people around us you
know it's not about shouting down the
royalists or spoiling anyone's day it's
about just being a part of the day
um as a voice of opposition so
uh yeah we don't want to
we want to we're very clear that we want
to project ourselves you know in the
image of Republicans um in a positive
light as well but I think that people
accept that yeah obviously if there's a
big broad event these days then it's
perfectly reasonable to protest today at
it if you're a Republican and at risk of
me getting sent to the tower um tell us
where that main protest is
so the main process is going to be on
Trafalgar Square just near where the
procession passes through
um and there will be smaller protests
along the mount and on Whitehall thank
you very much Graham appreciate you
joining us
our political education Falls rights in
this week's magazine about Sue gray and
Simon case are the pairs Fates entwined
she joins me now to discuss Katie you
write in this week's column about how
these two civil servants one former one
current have had their Fates entwined
Simon case and Sue gray tell us how this
came to be
it's a real in a civil service fight one
could say whereby there are two
appointments at Simon case was of course
appointed by Boris Johnson some time ago
and but a beleaguered cabinet secretary
successive scandals brought back to
light uh because of the Richard Sharp
roll-up last week which is the British
shop stepping down as BBC chairman over
his link to a loan for Boris Johnson his
defense was effectively that he didn't
tell the BBC appointments process or
others about this because he told Simon
case the cabinet secretary he thought
that was enough it turns out it wasn't
and Simon case doesn't remember the
exact details of that conversation and
perhaps conveniently and some more
questions about Simon case and then you
have Sue gray former senior super
servant Who was appointed by kirst armor
as his chief of staff back in March but
can't actually take that role on yet
because it has to go through two
investigations to see if she broke the
civil service code and not declaring
conversations with the labor party when
she should have done and of course labor
did not announce it was first reported
in the press and and they're entwined
not just because Simon case clearly has
a role right now in terms of leading the
Civil Service
um on how they handled the suit gray
situation
um but because if C grade does become
Chief of Staff it's very unlikely that
Simon case would be cabinet secretary
labor would not keep him so um they both
perhaps can't exist in the same house
yeah I mean that's the question was
first of all Sue gray has this kind of
really backfired because he wanted to be
in place probably six to eight months
before an election to have a lot of
transition planning is in our sense that
the advisors become the story and
actually you could have had a number of
probably senior impressive people rather
than the one person who's liked to cause
the most controversy yeah and I think
that's actually it in the sense Sue gray
has become the story so I think labor
have said that they will appoint her
whatever
um Akbar said because the second
investigation will ultimately rule on
the terms of her appointment and it
could delay it saying you know it
couldn't do today by a year saying she
can't start to this time next year and
here are the conditions and what she can
actually advise on giving her prior
knowledge of things so you could
basically make the appointment
complicated and and so forth and but I
think given labor say they will wait any
time and they will still have her as
chief of staff that there are some who
don't this is this will happen and how
how is she going to perform as a chief
of staff because what they want her
really there for is the planning for
government there's obviously a bit
harder if she doesn't start too much
nearer the next election and then also
you have a situation by which I think
because there is so much media around
her we have seen successive
um you know special advisors government
advisors as soon as you're the person
being written about the most it tends to
not go very well for you and you look
you know back to Alistair Campbell but
also Dominic Cummings
um for a while was a gift to journalist
everywhere but once you become a gifted
journalist and you eventually figures
think why is this person getting all the
attention and also you have a lot more
scrutiny you're supposed to be in the
shadows not not the main person
um and then if even if you think
actually back to you know David canzini
and he was a senior figure in one of you
know the various later stages of Boris
Johnson's
and again going to Harry exactly both
became the story and that always creates
attention and so so I think that it just
means the appointment is becoming
trickier for labor even if they are
still adamant that she is the person
they want you highlight in this piece
rightly that their Fates are entwined
together I mean surely there's a
scenario there's a likely scenario which
is that regardless what happens to sue
gray they've won the next election and
on day one kiss time is probably likely
to show the door to Simon case maybe
with Sue gray as the chief of staff yes
so I think that's little love lost
between Simon case and see gray
particularly at this point given the the
various uh you know investigations and
student grade not of course working with
the cabinet office one and the allies of
Sue gray will say they think Simon case
has a vendetta against her now and as
the Simon case will deny that so we'll
get the Ally part of this um interview
out of the way as we don't get into
trouble
um but
there is very little chance it's hard to
imagine a scenario Simon case would stay
on his cabinet secretary not just
because of his relationship with Steve
Gray but also the fact I think that
Kirsten critical of Simon case and he is
seen as a very political cabinet
secretary he was appointed I say in the
piece because
um by Boris Johnson but back when
Dominic Cummings was riding high and you
know speaking to figures who are in at
number 10 they said he was effectively
led to be Dominic having stooge and let
let Dom be Dom was the phrase
um so so I think there's doubts in his
ability to drive the machine and so
therefore you so it's hard to imagine
Sue gray being a number 10 at the same
time as Simon case
um in the future I think the question is
does that mean when you're looking at
Simon case there's it's very easy to
find civil servants being very critical
of him at the moment but it's much more
sympathy for him in government I think
it's partly because there's a better the
devil you know stance but also if we
just think cynically for a second if you
have a cabinet secretary who ultimately
will lose their job likely if a labor
government comes in
that probably is some advantage to that
territory government
very true and also there's a lack of
successes as well because you had Tom
scholar recently leave the treasury as
well talking to some civil servants
there seems to be a sort of a wider
crisis here right that's the that's what
ultimately both of these figures point
to is that we've had a real problem in
British politics with process the Civil
Service in recent years a lot of crises
happen with covert and brexit
um do you think this is going to be
cleared off anytime soon so I think is
is quite clear no matter what
angle service is not
in the relationship with the government
and and not just about briefing Wars but
how do you drive the Machinery of
government both Simon case's appointment
a few years ago and then also Sue Graves
earlier this year are
um political leaders trying to work out
how to make the machine work for them
and
it's quite hard at the moment morale's
very low in the Civil Service and
there's lots to talk of civil service
reform
um I think that there's a problem there
in the sense that Richard doesn't have
long really before the next election so
it's not seen as a key voter priority
even though there are some in government
who would like that to be something that
happens before the next election and
then I think for labor and there is a
risk that they are almost lionizing the
civil service so they are saying the
Civil Service can do no wrong apart from
a course when they're turning on pursue
gray
um in the form of Simon case and does
that mean that if they do get into Power
it's harder to then
um challenge civil servants because all
governments have these problems it might
be more heightened under a Tory
government but the various rhetoric but
a labor government would soon come into
many of these issues too great thanks
Casey
out of Scotland it's 16 years this week
since the SMP came to power so join me
to discuss that anniversary in The Wider
debate around Scotland's future is Alex
salmon the former first Minister who now
leads the Alba party
Alex thank you for joining us today on
special TV
um first of all we got into Scottish
politics uh the monarchy you're down
here currently um demonstrating is that
correct about no I'm doing my
pre-correlation tour that's what I leave
before the coronation
uh I I I I promise a ballot as if you
know this to to get in a ballot of privy
councilors uh like myself and what
members of parliament
and I didn't know this until I got
phoned by a member of parliament to be
nameless who was very miffed about the
situation and wondered if I might
complain about it given that you reckon
that probably didn't want to go anyway
you know so we didn't have any
self-interest in the matter as it were I
declined because I thought it was bigger
issues at state but obviously I've got a
sneaking sympathy for him you know we've
got coronation where you know uh Charles
uh will have invited every you know
ecologist vegetarian
the Anton deck a seat for them both
apparently uh that you can think of but
there's not a seat for every Member of
Parliament the elected house
which I think is a bit much actually I
mean I don't really care as I said
because I'm not a member of Obama
anymore but it's a bit strange also it's
pretty insane I would have thought for
the new king to offend so many members
of the elected house so that's the
situation apparently apart from the
leaders of the political parties
everybody else has got to stick their
their name in a ballot and if you know
if you come out in the raffle then you
get to The Abbey if you get second prize
you get to go in the tent and Victoria
Gardens uh which I think it's a very
strange way to to run a coronation but
well hey ho it's up to up to King
Charles I certainly have a lot of
disgruntletory MPS and uh speaking of
disgruntled parliamentarians uh what is
the mood like would you say in terms of
The Wider Independence Movement but also
what's going on with the SMP right now
well the SMP is obviously in a lot of
trouble
an existential crisis but whether it's
uh Extinction event or one of these big
bumps in the road but it's certainly a
pothole it's people it's more than a
bump it's a portable at least
and then the penicillin is doing all
right I mean Independence I mean it's
quite interesting if you go back to 2011
you know a year I like remembering
because you know we wanna a majority in
a proportional Parliament which is a
little tricky and and the SMP sport I
think was 45 percent
but support for Independence was below
30 percent
now we've got almost to the verse well
the very first I mean SMP support is
tumbling down the 30s just now will I
support for Independence is it 45 and
above in some pools so Independence
supports doing fine
SMP support is in a lot of trouble
because the SMP is in trouble now
whether harms the use of can you know
pull himself out of that poison chalice
or not remains to be seen Yousef I mean
what's he like as a minister do you
pointed him I did yes I have before that
an employer I gave them not just his
first ministerial job I gave him his
first job in my constituency office and
peterhead so it's a perfect nice guy
perfectly able therefore intelligent
well there's up to to this sort of
situation
or whether it did any new first Minister
would be I mean it's it's not an easy
situation I mean in a way if Kate Forbes
well Ash Reagan who will the the woman
candidates against the Hamza they would
have been in a better position because
they were clearly Outsiders so they
wouldn't have had to say look all this
mess has got nothing to do with me
people would have understood that and
believed that that harms us the
continuity candidate as a real
difficulty and for some reason I'm
unsure of instead of doubling down which
is what he should have done I mean he
should have had a you know a Berlin Wall
between him and everything had gone
before he should have you know sacked
everybody or put them in gardening leave
or whatever you do these days and made
it clear that it was nothing to do with
him he seems to feel even though there
is now no longer sings the continuity
candidate it's the edging his way to
distancing himself from the poisoned
Legacy he's not doing enough of it I
mean the first thing he should have done
in these circumstances which are
extremely difficult is to clear the
decks but is that possible I mean
yesterday was the 16th anniversary of
that 2007 election where the s p came to
power after such a long time actually
any party of any political complexion
was have difficulty Reinventing itself
I think it was preventive examples a
parties renewing themselves in power I
mean you know the you know the Liberals
in Japan I mean they went on forever
every time the opposition thought they
were getting somewhere on the other
stuff I like to the new leader changed
the nature I mean a lot of parties can
do that I mean it's not easy and of
course parties do acquire bad habits you
know complacency time service Hangers On
and you know the trouble with SMP in the
last few years is showing all the signs
of oh I don't know the labor party in
Scotland in the 1980s and 90s I mean I
look at the ranks of the SMP and I I go
back to when I was in Parliament with
you know 50 labor MPS down in the 19
early 1990s and you know what it's
Animal Farm isn't it you know
the the two species of kind of Mayor so
there are difficulties we've been in
power a long time but if you're a new
first Minister particularly you know a a
new Asian first Minister clearly
different from anything that's gone
before younger than the people have gone
before as well I mean at least they've
got the the start of saying you know
it's time for a new age you can engage
and renew
whether Hamza has got what it takes to
do that I mean I I don't think so is the
answer but but you know you can get get
surprised in politics you mentioned Kate
Forbes then there's been a lot of
reports around her plans those are the
Allies Etc you were in Hollywood for you
know 16 odd years what device would you
kind of give a tactically in terms of
maybe you know positioning yourself as a
candidate potentially between what
happened with somebody Yousef but also
trying to push a slightly different
policy agenda within the SMP well within
the SNP I would I if I would Kate
or giving an advice I I would I would
deploy one of the most underrated
political uh crafts it was one which I
didn't specialize in myself to tell the
two it's always easier to give advice
it's silence
within the SMB I would say nothing
out with the SMP doesn't matter and and
to some extensions already started that
it was quite interesting she did a a
paper with uh the think tank common
wheel no that was clever for two reasons
the subject matter was poverty and the
approach to it
and secondly common Wheels a left-wing
Think Tank and Kate obviously has been
accused I think about unjustly but
because of her social attitudes it's
been a student to some sort of classic
right winger you know The Spectator
candidate but a case of death well it
wouldn't be the case of life
to be fair she's she's not that at all
so I mean she comes from a tradition a
very honorable tradition
in Scottish politics see this sort of
Highland radical tradition
uh which kind of marked marched off in a
a fairly conservative social attitude
with a fairly radical political attitude
it leads to sort of people who you know
hang layers and landlords from the
nearest lampposts not you'd get many
lamp posts but nonetheless if there
wasn't available Lamppost that would
certainly hang the layers so it's not a
classic right of Center a position but
so it was a good move I would say a
clever move to to publish that pamphlet
with a left-wing Think Tank I mean that
shows a some pretty intelligent
repositioning I mean obviously you were
in the s p for so long and you know the
kind of feel for it you know the party
machines Etc the how you know how it all
sort of operates I mean what sort of if
you look at the history of the s p there
it's obviously been contested leadership
elections traditionally they were sort
of it's been quite a sort of central top
down control for most of its time in
government I mean can you have someone
like that you know try to will the
membership really go for someone like
that if they're seen as opposing the
leadership well I don't agree actually I
mean the smps has some I mean wolf times
I became leader
in 1990 and then again in 2004
uh they were pretty heavily contested I
mean in 1990 when I was a young photo
Snapper obviously Billy out of school
and you know I was very much the
outsider probably deservedly so looking
back and I was up against a lovely lady
called Mark Ewing a wonderful woman but
very much I mean a very able
parliamentarian a very vigorous campaign
and very much the favorite
so it was quite a contest and then in
2004 although banana became the favorite
when I entered the race but I had a bit
of Dilly dallying before I got to that
position so I wasn't expecting that I
would come back asleep though so these
were pretty strong contests and they
went on for a long time uh you know
months
you know for some reason which is only
known to a few I suspect the present
leadership election was rushed through
before people had much time to think
about it how do you see the next 18
months or so leading up to that general
election and then looking forward to the
2026 highly elections how do you see
that panning out in terms of the s p and
The Wider Independence Movement well I
mean obviously our speakers so I mean
I'm speaking not as a dispassionate
Observer
uh but the the rational thing to do is
twofold one because of the political
trials and tribulations of the s p it
would be a good idea to actively
intentionally separate the way the
national movement from the the SMP as
the governing party you do that to allow
it to campaign for independence with
Vigor you know unimpinged by the what's
going on in government meanwhile you get
on the government I mean Hamza yusuf's
biggest job is to get the government
back to something like competence you
know that'd be a real gain at the
present moment uh so that would unleash
what is a very strong movement you know
that is the 45 that's you know that's
the the think tanks the activist groups
the campaigners the petitioners
internationally all these groups there
were so many acronyms you could shake a
stick at them you know I mean it's to me
amazing but you let that let it free you
know let it let a thousand of Learners
bloom in the independence movement and
secondly you've got to face the
Electoral test
of a UK general election next year now
usually we've been in positions
historically where the SMP brand that's
been stronger than the independence
brand so at various times you know so if
I could be like myself find ways to to
square that Circle you know by saying
look you know we bought for me I bought
for the SMP and there'll be a referendum
in Independence in a different position
you're not in a position where the
independence brand is stronger than the
SMP brand so the intelligent political
thing to do is to come to an
accommodation between the pro
Independence parties which are the sap
by far still and dominant party alappa
the green party even you know friendship
part is like the Scottish socialists who
believe in Independence and make sure
there's one Independence candidate in
each parliamentary constituency
no the the balconies the vast bulk of
these would be SMP but they should stand
not just as SMP but as M SMP Scotland
United for Independence
a and the alap academy is far less
obviously would be alappa Scotland
United for Independence so with the
green candidates and so on and so forth
to get one Independence candidate now
the beauty of that is not just on one
candidate which is always an advantage
in the first pass the post-election but
an independence candidate so people
would be less worrying about the SMP and
its brand and its image it would be very
clear that what people are being asked
to do in that constituency was to back
the individual and back the concept of
Independence now fitness places in World
politics in similar situations that's
been tried highly successful that you
think of Quebec when the PQ that
particular was in a bit of trouble
hadn't had any success even contesting
Federal elections and then they formed
the block Quebec and it swept the boats
so there's good particles International
as to why that might be uh I mean it
could even take it as a parlor it's not
an exact part of you know a Lloyd George
did on the group an election you know
everybody you know the Welsh magician
managed to persuade everybody else to
stand you know whether they were
liberals or conservatives or labor for
that matter you know Lloyd George Cooper
and I know there was a light Josh Cooper
that got them elected
I say it's not an exact parallel but
that's a sort of a long
the sort of big move
that you need to make under the
circumstances that harms the user finds
himself in
the Temptation Of course is when you're
under Fire
like in the trenches the hunk up down
and hoping that shell doesn't hit you if
you do that I'm afraid the shell will
have your name on it what you have to do
is get over the top and find a way to to
shift the political debate
this week for example I mean I'm sure
Hamza doesn't see it this way but he got
very upset when I pointed out that you
know he as people of the Great Seal
could have stopped the stone of Destiny
coming down for the coronation
and he could have had if he wanted to a
political standoff on Scotland's rights
as a nation that's what the stone of
Destiny represents it represents
Scottish sovereignty that's why it was
taken stolen
pinched filched
from Scotland by Edward the first in the
first place he was eliminating all
traces of Scottish identity that's what
he was doing he was a highly intelligent
somewhat ruthless plant pageant King
so it's a symbol of Scottish sovereignty
and at a time when the government of the
day is not recognized I mean noticing
some Scottish sovereignty then let's
keep it with a great seal and therefore
in control of the fate of the stone and
Destiny
I first of all I could just said well
you're not having it politely but firmly
and would have commanded the
international attention of the world and
the standoff and the Esplanade of
Edinburgh Castle
and if he'd done that then people would
have been talking about Scotland's
rights as a nation
and they would have been talking about
this extraordinary Contra term between
Edinburgh and London and what they
wouldn't have been talking about was the
financial Wars of the Scottish national
party
you know all Hamza could see that was
that I was somehow criticizing them
about a lumper rock no trouble is if you
if you don't understand history
and the importance of it you don't
understand or command the present or for
that matter formulate the future thank
you Alex
now I'm joined by Oxford academic Toby
ORD to discuss the future of artificial
intelligence following Jeffrey hinton's
resignation this week from Google
Toby thanks for joining us what are your
thoughts on Jeffrey hinton's resignation
yes well uh Jeffrey Hinton is is a huge
name uh in Ai and especially uh deep
learning he uh was one of the people who
pioneered the approach of back
propagation which is how a neural
network learns and also deep neural
networks having very many layers in
order for them to be able to learn more
complex Concepts so it's hard to get a
bigger name in AI than the Jeffrey
Hinton and he's resigned from from
Google in part so that he can feel free
to to talk about the risks that this
technology that has helped develop might
pose
and what do you make of that I mean do
you think that actually AI does pose
these kind of risks that he's warning
about
it that it could this is an area where
there's a very wide range of opinion
among AI researchers uh but the Deep
concerns about the risks of AI arising
within that community and something like
half of the the foremost AI researchers
have now gone on the record expressing
concerns uh that's human extinction uh
could be a a possible uh consequence of
the technology that they're developing
or some permanent disempowerment of
humanity at the hands of AI systems the
other half uh many of them are also very
concerned about about risks that could
be posed although they think that
they're of a different kind and smaller
albeit still large risks to do with uh
discrimination and bias and
concentration of power and things along
those lines you mentioned their human
extinction rather casually
um Talk us through that how exactly are
we all going to die because of AI
yeah I think in some ways the the best
way to think of it well here are a few
ways to think of it so one is uh that
the reason that it's humans that are
calling the shots on planet Earth at the
moment
and where the fate of other species are
ultimately up to us
um uh is because of our intelligence
um and and generally our cognitive
abilities our ability to work with each
other to achieve goals and what we're
planning on doing or at least the AI
researchers are is developing new
entities that are better than us at this
unique attribute so I think the default
pathway there unless we do anything to
to prevent it would be that it's
ultimately these new things that are
calling the shots
so that's that's one way to look at it
and then if you say well what can you do
in order to ensure that they're aligned
with our interests or that they can
always obey our instructions uh that the
people who are working on that that
particular part of artificial
intelligence called AI alignment
research that they're actually leading
the concern uh that we're not going to
be able to develop those techniques in
time and that will have systems that are
more powerful than us before we have
systems that we know how to control
and Hinton in his interview asks us to
think about you know a baby with a
mother in terms of is that a sort of
useful analogy in terms of the control
relationship and also perhaps the sense
of an innocence or naivety in terms of
how little we know compared to what AI
would know
yeah it's it's I mean it's it's a
complex one because
um the the sense in which uh an infant
controls their their parents is quite
complicated and and it's not that
they're planning to do so or something
like that uh uh but his right to raise
this question about how often can a you
know less intelligent entity control of
a more intelligent one without the more
intelligent one eventually uh resting
that control away uh another example
that that he he could have used perhaps
is maybe a very intelligent uh criminal
who's been captured and put in prison
um can then be controlled ultimately uh
by the state and not able to escape from
the prison due to an asymmetry in the
position that the prisoner is now in
where they've been captured so there
could be something like that as well
where effectively because we can design
the constraints that our AI systems are
in that by designing those those
constraints and the the types of actions
they're allowed to take and so on and by
being able to observe those actions and
log them uh that that's another way that
we could hope to have some upper hand
over a system that's more powerful than
us and we may also be able to design its
goals um in an accurate way so that it's
aiming to uh to achieve the types of
things that lead to our flourishing
which would be another hope for
controlling a more intelligent system
although as I said that one seems to be
very difficult to do
and we're talking here in the UK now but
um how do different regimes around the
world compare in terms of their kind of
framework here I mean is there are some
countries putting ahead presumably
America is one of them and with AI what
are the kind of different nations
approaches to AI
yeah I mean I would say that that it's
pretty similar among the the leading uh
researchers on
um on AI uh there are a few uh leading
Labs working on what's called artificial
general intelligence and these are the
types of systems that that would aspire
to be able to do the wide range of tasks
that a human could do and to be able to
do it as well or better than a human
such as a deep mind here in London and
also uh open Ai and anthropic in Silicon
Valley
so they are working on uh among other
things uh training these these large
language models and so that's these chat
Bots and systems that can can read the
entire internet and then give seemingly
intelligent responses uh to the types of
questions that we ask them and the tasks
that we set for them
and I mean in this piece you know Hinton
suggests we could reach uh artificial
German intelligence with about 20 years
how realistic a time scale is that
because you know many people's
experience of chat GPT might be you know
it's it's interesting it's a useful
guide but they can't see really how that
kind of evolves over the next few years
and decades
yeah um and uh in the in the interview I
see that uh Hinton
acknowledges it that
it's we don't want to just reason from
ignorance to say we can't see how it
would get there so therefore it can't
get there but but nor do we want to just
assume the opposite uh ultimately we
need to acknowledge that we're in a
position of of quite deep uncertainty
whenever it comes to predicting the
pathway of a rapidly developing
technology
and I think that what some people don't
recognize is that the uncertainty
doesn't mean that you're entitled to to
believe whatever you want to believe and
similarly the diversity of opinion among
AI researchers doesn't mean that they
can have any opinion they want and just
just you know take it out to the Grave
ultimately
we need to acknowledge that that there
is a great deal of uncertainty and and
um and disagreement about what's going
to happen and that we don't know how to
take possibilities such as human
extinction off the table at the moment
and that's deeply alarming even if we're
not saying that that it's certain to
happen yeah I mean you mentioned there
about the disagreement and we've spoken
about how half the community seems to be
very divide and hostile about this
yet I mean despite hinton's resignation
earlier this week causing headlines lots
of news stories about it it seems we're
racing ahead regardless even though as
you say a half of the uh sort of
community involved with this are deeply
opposed just will this resignation have
any effect and what really is going to
slow down this race to AI because where
I'm standing I can't really see anything
stopping it
that's a good question
um and as as Hinton mentions uh part of
the concern is a certain kind of race
Dynamic
um there is uh that when Microsoft uh
launched their new Bing
um uh which I think was something of a
fiasco uh but it it's in an attempt to
outdo Google ad search which is Google's
core product uh it then kind of forced
Google's hand to deploy systems that it
was previously uh not deploying and that
triggering a race between these um these
huge uh corporations uh to develop you
know better and better AI systems as
quickly as possible and we saw with Bing
that it was really not ready for prime
time it was definitely not aligned with
human interests I mean it was the first
AI system to threaten to kill an AI
ethics researcher and also in terms of
Journalism it threatened an AP
journalist uh it threatened to expose
them for war crime which they as far as
I know had not committed because it had
written a bad story about Bing which
being assumed must be false because it
was taught to believe that it was always
correct about things so these are you
know sci-fi plot lines right uh that
that where that have become real now
this system while it threatens revenge
on people who say bad things about it on
the internet uh it can't fulfill that
revenge and probably it's not going to
kill anyone but I don't think we can
wait until people are killed by an AI
system before we actually uh try to
regulate it or at least take some some
serious steps otherwise people are going
to get killed before before we take
action
well I'm not cheering note thank you
very much Toby for joining us today and
finally Shriver joins me now to discuss
the Fallout from tackle Carlson's
departure from Fox News last week now
Lionel you write in this week's magazine
about Tucker Carlson and there's a line
here in which you say that um television
appearances rattle me and my first
instinct is to try to get out of them so
we're very grateful that you've joined
us today on spec TV
um you've written this week about soccer
Carlson explain to us why you're
motivated to write about this following
his recent axing from the Fox News
Network
so it really has to do with the fact
that it has changed the nature of my
evenings
um so I feel
I feel personally impacted
uh this column is a bit of a confession
because uh in the United States in the
circles that I run in
saying that you ever watched Tucker
Carlson uh
demonizes you for all times
decided I needed to come clean that I
feel personally aggrieved
um
I force feed myself a certain amount of
heavily left-wing mainstream media on a
daily basis you know I watch the channel
4 news every night I watched the PBS
NewsHour on YouTube from the United
States when it goes live uh at midnight
I keep atrocious hours
and then Tucker Carlson is put on
YouTube at 2AM which is right around the
time that I'm flossing my teeth
um and
uh it's a relief
now I made it very clear that uh I don't
agree with everything he says uh there
are any number of quite important
matters I disagree with him on you know
he has not advocated uh the uh the big
lie on the Trump
loss in 2020 I say loss
uh not nearly as much as a lot of other
Fox hosts have though he has kept the
door open to it and you know to me
that's a that's a disappointment I wish
that he had renounced it and their whole
other range of issues you know abortion
I'm I support abortion access he's not
too keen on it but there are other
issues that I agree with him on and it's
a relief to see them represented in the
media and you can't find it these
positions
represented with Brio
anywhere else and
um
you know my my main point is that he's
entertaining he's fun to watch it's it's
enjoyable even when I disagree with him
the delivery is
[Music]
um
it's skillful it's uh
it's it's persuasive in it in a not
badgering way he's not hitting you over
the head it's uh
it's it's very well packaged he comes
across as appealing yeah yeah I have no
idea what he's really like as a person
and so I can only speak for
what he is like as a media personality
but the reason the left hates him so
much is that he's so good at what he
does I mean it that's that's his whole
thing that's why he drives them crazy
and that's the that's the few people
who've actually watched him because
typically in the United States uh most
of the people who really reviled Tucker
Carlson have never watched him
well that's fascinating as you say by
having a great comparison there you know
Tucker Carlson does really seem to stand
out from a lot of the kind of uh
punditry in America do you think there's
perhaps a sense I mean you write in the
piece you talk about sort of how many
pundits are fun to watch do you think
that he perhaps has that that kind of
sense of being able to to rise out of
those kind of left-right divides because
he does seem to attract you know a huge
number of people across the Spectrum in
a way in which most people in Fox can't
do and is it that sense of fun really
that sets him out apart and why doesn't
other networks have someone like Tucker
Carlson frankly
I think they're rare and and originality
is not often promoted these days it's uh
mediocrity is promoted and he's a
Maverick a genuine Maverick uh Sarah
Palin ruined that word for some time but
I think we can take it back
uh and he isn't always a straight down
the line Republican which is one of the
reasons that he makes a lot of
Republicans nervous because
you know he he isn't a party
animal he likes thinking about things
there's a consistency to his viewpoints
but that doesn't mean that they hang
together in a in a party political way
and I think that's one reason that uh he
makes Fox nervous
he's
you know it's been fascinating to me how
big this story has become you know it's
just one pundit
the size of his audience is often quoted
like 3.3 million people
out of uh 340 million Americans that's
not that big
uh but it's regarded as a of enormous
political importance and it's it's
really shaking up the media landscape
and everyone is on the edge of their
chairs wondering what he's going to do
next so he must be enjoying this in a
way I have a feeling he did not enjoy
getting fired but
um
he's in he's in a position of remarkable
amount of power and ability to call his
own shots right now yes because I mean
other people have left the Fox News
firmament people like Bill O'Reilly Etc
and haven't really had the kind of same
impact or clout that they did on that
Network do you think perhaps Tucker
Carlson is an exception because of as
you say uh Lionel those those talents
that ability to have a sense of fun
which means that he's not just confined
to the narrow world of kind of
conservative politics but is rather a
bigger personality who could probably
find a platform elsewhere
well you know you've got people like uh
Andrew Sullivan uh claiming that he
should run for president I I um I'd be
surprised if he did I don't he's
repeatedly said that he doesn't have any
political Ambitions and he's clearly
good at what he does and I don't see why
he would want to not
keep doing it
um
being president is kind of a drag uh I
think most people think it's all about
campaigning and attention and pomp but
actually you have to make a lot of
decisions and read a lot of crap that is
incredibly boring and uh
and I think that that the pomp gets
tiresome I think the whole thing gets
tiresome I don't understand why most
people who who who become president won
a second term
even Trump I don't know I think he wants
to run for president I'm not convinced
he wants to be president again
so I I'd be surprised if
Carlson went for a political option
but it will be a very interesting test
of
um how well you can do outside of
mainstream media outlets and there are
other examples like Joe Rogan who has a
huge audience
and
and a much bigger one that he would get
on on like a cable news show so we'll
see what what Carlson does I I
I will be intrigued and it's not
impossible either that he just
disappears I mean that that can happen
but he's a very talented uh newscaster
he's a he's a whatever you think of his
positions with which I as I noted I
differ a lot
especially on Ukraine
um but he's you know he is
he's gifted as a um a Persuader and as
an Entertainer and he's smart he's very
smart he's well educated so he a lot of
the people on Fox come across as frankly
poorly educated
um and uh their style of persuasion is
Clumsy and obvious
they're often just as Earnest as the
liberal commentator and uh the error on
the side of the snide which is not a
good look
uh
Carlson is Head and Shoulders above all
of these people at Fox
and I just I just think that he's
something of a Sweden heiress and a one
of a kind and
Fox is going to have a very hard time
replacing him uh in that eight o'clock
slot yes and in terms of replacing him I
mean he has been the kind of most
Ukraine skeptic voice in American
mainstream media do you see anyone
stepping in to fill that Gap will that
view be articulated or is it perhaps a
case of you know this is just not going
to be a view that's articulated going
forward certainly not on Fox or any of
the mainstream platforms
I think the um
opposition to supporting zielinski
is not seen as a very winning
Republican position
uh there is pretty broad bipartisan
support for the uh for military at
Ukraine right now in the United States
and uh
Carlson is one of the only people
in a in a prominent position who is
saying you know this is shouldn't be our
problem we should be we should be saving
the money uh for opposing China and
um
you know there are there are all these
bad things that go on in the world all
the time and we can't we can't fix them
we have to we have to pick our spots you
know Carlson is something of an
anti-interventionist
uh
yeah I just don't hear that anywhere
else now I I think that that that means
that there's a place for it if we're
going to have an intelligent discussion
about that much money and an issue of
that much consequence
then we need to hear all sides of the
issue and so while I'm when I'm
listening to Carlson on Ukraine I'm busy
disagreeing with him but I'm interested
in the argument and I'm glad someone is
making it
uh if only you know when you do have an
intelligent discussion about something
from more than one side then it it
pushes you to refine your own position
and to come up with a reply so I mean
that's
that is what we are supposed to be doing
in the media now that Tucker's gone who
will be watching instead
um funnily enough uh
I've been watching uh Victor Davis
Hanson videos
he's even more drastic than Carlson is
I think I've I've just crawled further
down the rabbit hole
well thank you very much Joe's inspect
TV Lionel appreciate it
that's it for this week once again thank
you to kind of cool genuity wealth
management for sponsoring the week in 60
minutes Calico will provide you with the
expertise you need to help build your
wealth with confidence visit can do
wealth.com for more information thanks
again for joining and I hope to see you
next week
[Music]
thank you